To answer the question, how many
patients are in the 30 mile radius for
hospital one,
we'll review the solution work flow.
Because the hospital's geo-coded file
already has a spatial object on it
we can immediately move to
creating trade areas for it.
In the trade area tool, we specify
the trade area sizes as 10, 20,
30, putting a comma between each value.
Next we move to the patient's file, and
notice that while it has a LATITUDE and
LONGITUDE field,
there is no spatial object.
So we use the Create Points
tool to add the point locations
pointing to the latitude and
longitude fields.
In the next step, we're simply
renaming the spatial object field for
the patients, so that it's
easier to recognize downstream.
Next, we configure
the spatial match tool
with the trade area in the target and
the patients in the universe area.
The method for
spatial matching is intersects.
Notice below, that for
every hospital trade area we'll
be able to attach a patient ID.
And because we simply want to count
patients in the hospital trade areas,
we can simply keep the patient ID field
and deselect the rest of the fields.
Out of the Spatial Match tool is a list
of patients that fall within each
hospital trade area, along with,
the trade area size and the patient ID.
To count the number of patients for each
trade area, we use the Summarize tool.
We group by on the name
of the hospital and
the radius size, and count the number
of patients by counting the patient ID.
To select the one record for
a 30 mile radius for
hospital one, we can use a filter
tool based on those two criteria.
The result is the count for
hospital one for
the 30 mile radius,
which is 497 patients.